a reported racist attack on a black man
by a group of white men is under
investigation in Indiana
the alleged victim posted video of the
incident on Facebook he's getting
support from people in the community who
held a rally yesterday to call for
action our national correspondent
Jericka Duncan says police are looking
into this claim that the men threatened
to string him up words trying to get out
of here guys a relaxing evening with
friends turned violent after five white
men allegedly attacked box Booker a
black man and pinned him against a tree
please let him go
Booker a civil rights activist in
Bloomington Indiana said the men dragged
him beaten and threatened to break his
arms noose they literally said the term
noose Booker says the confrontation
began when the men accused him and his
friends of trespassing the men allegedly
started yelling white power among other
racial slurs ttyn mayor John Hamilton
said he was horrified by the attack and
acknowledges that racism still exists in
his community these are really painful
times it's a painful episode on Monday
hundreds of protestors gathered around
the Monroe County Courthouse to demand
justice for Booker but the peaceful
demonstration ended in
after a car rammed into two people one
woman was taken to the hospital no
charges have been filed yet meanwhile
Booker's waiting for charges to be filed
against his alleged attackers and says
he's grateful for those who stepped in
to save him I think the reason why I'm
here today is because folks stop being
bystanders and they became active
participants and I hope that we continue
to see that movie donation officers did
respond to that incident Saturday after
Booker says he called 911 because
officers didn't make any arrests now
people are calling for those officers to
be investigated and suspended because
they didn't take immediate action tareka
I don't have any words for what you just
showed us it's deeply sad deeply
troubling and very very frightening
thank you